bien commencé pour sa part 73 venez en
sautant bon ok au maïs grillé jabouille
détruisit ok c'est aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur 200 figurants qui est
assurée vole donc comme d'hab ce qui
s'appelle la france ans maïwenn sauf que
là c'est pas des tombes fil aux attaques
mais c'est des dinosaures oui dédié aux
arts sauf que cette fois stefan wilson
pourquoi je prends c'est moi je sais pas
mais j'ai joué avec mes cailloux et
artères on s'est bien marré vrai je
propose de lancer le jingle puis
d'enchaîner sur la vidéo du single photo
tient au bon jouer le chien comme anvers
et bosh crèche me lâche le arrête
nouveau à de bouger le tir à temps je
mets le doigt et je les voyais et
annoncer ça fait quoi si je fais ça où
est alors je crois que ça faisait je
crois que ça faisait genre une chaîne
tout faux car de bouger mais cas
d'accouplement show un peu les toiles de
mai vient de meurs meurs avaient tous un
tipi sans déconner si non mais comme on
arrête tu as tu es tu sais mais tu l'as
tuée
les quatre ans il ya certaines choses
rencontre où j'allais jouer bon c'était
la répartie de mika même complice soit
le type y aura moins 6 mois et 12 jours
s'est nouée
oui c'est quoi mon gars c'est pas tout
mais c'est peut être moi ouais c'est bon
attends tu m'as fait quoi alors
ces momies car je vais t'aider moyens
d'innover gaffe
rhodia est bon pour la tuer allez prenez
le temps d avoir poussé vous poussez
vous poussez vous poussez vous poussez
vous bossez seulement si tu y as quoi
manip et umap et à ma viande
j'espère du voleur ce texte avec la
sortie comme médias serbes
on s'est fait amputer marrant jour
caisse avec la jauge éléments dont
certains il est dans les abysses de
l'ama pour le retrouvera jamais la lame
à neige fraîche manche est en train de
marcher depuis 6 heures je vous avoue
tipi c'est bon les gars tiens un t-rex y
arriver il ya un t-rex qu'arrive le mec
un train couper du bois et va se faire
couper la tête de porc vas-y fac note
les mecs ont participé what i boîte
boîte isérois au [ __ ] mais terminé
mais tu m'as tué dans la mentalité mois
brad et moi il ya pas moi je te parle de
me demander mon talent est remonté et je
n'ai pas planté il est planté wade
décidé d'évoluer à trois ans de
questions et luca luca apprend à viser
un je suis pas de dino mois est désolé
franchement je le mets qui m'a mis deux
flèches te plaise 2 pas qu'une tout cas
fait une cage et moi et c'est pour
mettre quoi des dinos 1 à servette a
fait une cage
c'est pour mettre des gens comme parent
est allé bien arrêtées ont dit non pas
loin tout le monde me suit
ah ah [ __ ] les mecs aient fait exprès
il est vraiment consulat et ou aux héros
et irak tué c'est le deal au replay
[Musique]
hugo fils de chien stay alive rivage au
merci aux anges moi je suis là les mecs
c'est quoi des inspections des lieux
s'il vous plaît il peut me ramener de
pierre je t'appelle lucas ok ok je
faisais la réflexion ils se trouvent
avait retrouvé de la pierre pour son
pote qu'elle est c'est parti le mec art
est le [ __ ] moi je suis chef de la
tribu mois et qui déjà je cherche dans
les débuts du bruit alors je crois
qu'ils bloquent surtout nous fait une
sorte de toit et dinosaures enfin c'est
encore le thouars qu'avec notre bouclier
à la date
alors oui je vais planter bougent pas
assez médias airbags
c'est moi qui ai passé ma fille
s'appelait alors si on trouve ainsi dans
le but et on fait un feu de camp on
bouffe jours on peut nager ou pas je
m'en bats les couilles hall défense
l'armée mais qui va nous au hockey va
mourir
il s'appelle deux parties j'ai décoché
après un flèche et belle équipe est
bonne on profite le gard tamer je vais
au café des pourquoi attend le mec qui
te met un coup de queue mongai boules de
pétanque
non mais oh c'était à qui est-il et la
messagerie et le coca qui a voulu
attaquer un dinosaure qui déjà de base
ressemble à un caillou géant après on
part à la pêche on va rigoler que
j'imaginais genre le gender peut-être
que j'étais polaha les magazines strates
perçu comme un fait c'est entre deux
dalles de la vente vous et moi je sais
que tu meurs je m'en bat auxerre des
passerelles voilà non qu'est super avec
mes poissons pas à mes camarades et
bouger flèche un de bouger flèche faut
que je suis à rabat où j'ai flèche à la
débauche et flèches à temps mais c'est
sa malle à aulas va-t-il ces prêts à
jamais et enfin steak de vieux mec avec
leurs gros
le groupe avait dit est qu on tue un
dinosaure qui fait ses 200 kg ok je vois
pas du tout où est-ce qu'elle va mal ans
ou au ccib
oh je te plante on avait là rien au
diagnostic vous cramer michael ont pu
être comestible
le djia il est cramé mon gars regardez
chargé de le manger chez obligé de le
manger mais avec mr foot mais vas-y je
vois pas où mais flèche est bon là haut
au le chassa bim bam et a vu comme je
respecte autant c'est à moi ça moi je te
montre mes talons quand même à temps
mais qui marche sur l'eau et il
s'enfonce dans l'eau ils sont restés
cois la dernière fois c'était ça mes
talents attendu car martin les étoiles
et de protéger les mineurs la cub alors
j'ai pris la grosse j'ai pris la grosse
île à genève où il y avait des morts du
coup j'ai perdu du poids et chaque fois
les pandores concerne tous contrats dits
non attends je mange en train de faire
la lessive au radier de l'arctique comme
une bûche comme ça je fais de la pierre
mois en fait où s'entassent bien mais
qui se bat avec sa torche enflammée dit
évoquant des faits c'est non
il arrive ce mec
qu'est ce que je fais avec ma casse toi
regarde et l'inde ont ils seront fêtés
fait à la hâte en est à son mieux au
trou du cul déjà tu calmes et espace va
dans un premier temps vous êtes tous
mangé certain talent focus et cinq
dinosaures qui nous a violé aux
annonceurs nous attend pourquoi vous
éclaire c'est quoi ça au bailliage est
un il est une plante fils de chien ta
voix c'est une culée aux mêmes plants
on peut monter un dino effet un dino
pour un chacun ou non non retard talent
puisqu'il a pris la plante que pour moi
non mais
mais pas de soucis on attends je vais
aller le voir de près je suis qu aujourd
hui la disparue ont mais vas-y mon se
cassent les couilles albert ces mecs là
dans dix minutes quoi sur ce mec est
l'évêque regarder et un film comme et
éco message est passé
notre budget a dit le bon gars est une
voie de beauté enfin vicat oui oui je
vois aussi côté je pense mais qu'at t ou
ouais bah je suis là tu vois oui ça
c'est bon de caisse ouais ouais
ça va du pont rompu c'est moi qui
faisais plein à tintin tintin à tan
rouge
[ __ ] élections c'est sur cette
trahison que se termine cette vidéo que
j'espère que ça vous aura plu c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas à aller mais sa frappe
a visé on se tourne très vite dans une
nouvelle vidéo chat le monde pis
et voilà le rangement c'est parti
[Musique]
je suis
p